a legend in the National Basketball
Association wants to try hostage
negotiation will Dennis Rodman put on
eyeliner to go and save Brittany Greiner
that's a good one
and NBA Hall of Famer Dennis Rodman says
he's headed to Russia to help get
Brittany Greiner back you'll recall
Greiner an American
WNBA player is currently being held
there on a nine-year prison sentence for
cannabis possession hopefully she can
return to the U.S where her only
punishment would be having a play in the
WNBA
uh according to Rodman he's received
permission to travel overseas to Aid her
return although it should be noted that
nobody knows who if anyone authorized
Rodman to work in a diplomatic capacity
back in 2017 Dennis Rodman claimed to
have helped negotiate the return of
American Auto warm beer who was held
captive in North Korea and Rodman
famously has had a chummy relationship
with North Korea's dictator Kim Jong-un
now he says he also knows Vladimir Putin
too even calling him cool in a 2014
interview
whether or not Dennis actually travels
to Russia is like a WNBA game we don't
know if anyone will ever see it but
but full disclosure everyone I'm a
little biased so before we get into the
uh discussion we got to play this quick
so Kathy's Dennis Rodman is really
really hot and always has been so please
excuse everything she's about to say if
you disagree with it it's not her fault
he's so hot
[Music]
it's true everyone's like is she joking
I'm not joking uh Douglas I've had a
huge crush on Dennis Rodman since I was
five years old am I gonna be okay
you want him to come and save you what
what I have
I feel like now I have to play harder to
get than that you should take drugs to
Russia
I know I knew that if Greg wasn't here
then we'd have to do a cat drugs joke or
something oh I guess anyhow no um it's
it's very strange I was I was in North
Korea some years ago and I discovered
that that people there know almost
nobody from the outside world almost
nobody I mean they're like heard of chem
and Mao and they've heard of Dennis
Rodman
can you imagine what a strange world
that is they like think he's some like
magical guy well I was gonna say like he
would they think he's like Kofi Annan or
something he's like some new
international Diplomat and they don't
seem to realize that here he's Dennis
Rodman and only only you have this great
love of him and yeah anyhow you've loved
North Korea no they hold him in the same
esteem that you do look if you could
control who you do and do not think is
hot like that that'd be better but
[Laughter]
okay but like Dagan who would be a
better negotiator do you think Joe Biden
or Dennis Rodman Dennis Rodman is always
great to put on display because it
reminds all young people that facial
piercings don't age very well
um
but I did start thinking if I got stuck
overseas because I had like weed juice
in my suitcase who would I want to come
rescue me
and I figured Russell Crowe he's
Australian he doesn't need to get
permission from the U.S government and
even though he's pretty puffy now
I'm still down and made him
[Applause]
he's looking at me like that
I've gotten used to it over seven years
I'm just so happy Robin has a job so
yeah that's cool I'm sure your husband
was stoked about it oh he's already he
already knows yeah
yeah you know
Dennis Rodman built a reputation as one
of the most ferocious athletes on the
planet he drove guys crazy on the court
and he had this cult following overseas
because he did stuff that no one else
could do he defended people he got like
20 he was annoying everyone wanted to
punch him and beat him up but then he
was insanely tough and so these
dictators they kind of were drawn to him
because he was like if they played
basketball that's how they because they
couldn't shoot to save their lives in
basketball people they're good at it but
you should see their stats it's
phenomenal yeah but uh oh I gotta be
careful but uh you know he had that
reputation where Michael Jordan we all
loved him here in bottom shoes but
overseas Dennis Rodman was something
special plus I think deep down young and
Putin they kind of wanted to do the
hairdo and the piercings and stuff so he
made relationships with them they just
like seeing him like this is how I want
to be I want to be tough and pretty so
he's probably the best choice to go
because they let him over we're saying
we don't know who led him over Putin let
him over yeah we just you know don't
want to get him mad at us you know and
so if we have some more issues with
China and the trade since they won't let
Trump negotiate anymore send Dennis over
there he'll probably fix it for us he'll
get those backed up boats over here so I
don't care how he sprays it paints It
Whatever he'll go over there I bet he
brings her back yeah because he's Dennis
Robin
foreign
you think he can do it it's really in a
pickle here between you know the whole
Rodman Biden thing because when you
think about past performance on the
world stage though like one guy always
flies to other countries and does sound
like he's on drugs and the other guy's
Dennis Rodman you know
David we got nothing to lose Tyrus is
right at the very least Brittany Greiner
will get a contact high off Rodman you
know which is good but the whole truth
of it is I don't know what else we're
supposed to do because there's really
been no movement on this you feel like
under past administrations we would be
in a very assertive level of engagement
right now but I do still believe that
Biden thinks WNBA is a radio station in
Delaware so nothing's going to happen
that's Lonnie Anderson
reception all right well Dennis I
believe in you and also I may be married
but I'm not dead okay
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else